fest steht die erde ist ein wasser
planet rund drei viertel der
erdoberfläche ist von ozean bedeckt
außerdem gilt wasser als ursprung allen
lebens auf der erde doch noch immer ist
nicht endgültig geklärt woher das ganze
wasser stammt etwa durch die einschläge
von kometen und asteroiden auf der
jungen erde
so jedenfalls die gängige theorie doch
jetzt gibt es einen neuen super
spannenden ansatz von einem us
forschungsteam
und dabei spielt die sonne eine
erhebliche rolle demnach könnte nämlich
auch der solare uhr nebel
der ursprung des frischen wassers sein
wie das genau abgelaufen sein könnte und
warum das die existenz von
außerirdischem leben viel
wahrscheinlicher macht erfahrt ihr jetzt
bei pixum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierend des
seins videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts herzlich
willkommen bisher geht man davon aus
dass wohl asteroiden und kometen das
irdische wasser mitbrachten als sie auf
die junge erde ein sturm hinweise darauf
geben die chemischen signaturen dieses
roten wassers und des wassers auf
asteroiden die sind sich nämlich sehr
ähnlich diese theorie wird so akzeptiert
obwohl das rätselhafte diskrepanzen gibt
beispielsweise die gigantischen
wasserreservoirs im tiefen inneren der
erde das gestein dort speichert nämlich
mindestens doppelt so viel wasser wie in
allen weltmeeren enthalten ist und seine
signatur gleicht dem wasser der
asteroiden eben nicht wirklich konkret
geht es um den gehalt von deuterium
dieser ist im wasser des tiefen
erdmantel ist deutlich niedriger als bei
massiven wasser ähnlich bei dem
wasserreichen kometen die ebenso nicht
wirklich in dieses bild passen durch die
raumsonde rosetta nämlich konnte man
herausfinden dass die isotopen signatur
des kometen was es eben nicht mit der
signatur der irdischen ozeane
übereinstimmt heißt also eine umfassende
erklärung dafür was damals auf der
jungen erde geschah kann diese theorie
nicht liefern und so tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit ohne unterlass
über die eine so spannende frage wie
genau kam das wasser auf die erde ein
neuer spannender ansatz kommt jetzt von
einem forschungsteam der arizona state
university
sie wollen die alte theorie erweitern
und beziehen sich dabei auf die sonne
genauer gesagt auf den solaren uhr nebel
denn dieser ist wohl das vorherrschende
reservoir für wasserstoff im frühen
sonnensystem gewesen so die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
dennoch gibt es eine diskrepanz die sich
wieder auf den deutschen gehalt bezieht
denn der solare wasserstoff enthält viel
zu wenig deuterium um tatsächlich das
ozean wasser geliefert haben zu können
doch das us team hat eine erklärung dazu
und die beginnt sehr früh nämlich als
die ur erde von einem magma ozean
bedeckt war und zudem umgeben von einer
uhr wolke diese zur gase des solaren
nebels an wodurch sich eine erste uhr
atmosphäre gebildet hat die reich an
wasserstoff war dieses band anders im
magma enthaltene eisen nachdem es sich
von dem blut flüssigem gestein gelöst
hatte als sich dann die erdschichten
bildeten sank das eisen in den erdkern
und nahm einen großteil des wasserstoffs
mit und jetzt aufgepasst die jetzt
kruste erstarrte langsam und das wasser
reicherte sich in ihr und im erdmantel
mit deuterium an bedingt dadurch dass
dort helium eine kleinere affinität zu
reisen hat als normaler wasserstoff und
dies zu einer trennung der isotope
führte auf die erdoberfläche gelangen
weiteres wasser und zwar durch die
einschläge von kometen und asteroiden so
entstanden dann stück für stück die
ozeane ihre neue theorie hat das os
forschungsteams in simulationen
überprüft zitat wir berechneten liegt
wie wasserstoff sich im geschmolzenen
mantel lösen konnte um wie viel davon im
erdkern gelandet wäre
dann verglichen wir diese werte mit
aktuellen terium anteilen aus proben des
tieferen erdmantel und tatsächlich auch
wenn die rede durch extraterrestrische
quellen wie er soeben genug wasserstoff
für sieben bis acht ozeane bekam stammt
eben nicht alles daraus bis zu 0,5
ozeane müssen nach berechnungen der
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus dem solaren uhr nebel stammen heißt
also konkret ein bis zwei moleküle von
100 molekül irdischen wassers stammen
demnach aus der wolke doch dieses uhr
wasser hat die erde in ihrem inneren vor
uns versteckt vier bis fünf ozeane sind
wohl im erdkern end
und das äquivalent von rund 2 ozeanien
im tieferen erdmantel so das
forschungsteam aus arizona
der rest hat dann wohl die welt mehr
gebildet diese neue theorie könnte durch
analysen von gesteinen überprüft werden
denn nicht nur wasserstoff sondern auch
edelgase stickstoff und kohlenstoff
müssten in das erdinnere gesunken sein
angenommen dass ich tatsächlich für ewig
langer zeit mal gase aus dem ur nebel im
irdischen magma ozean gelöst haben
sollten dazu einer der beteiligten
forscher schon wo diese gase solchen
isotopen spuren in der chemie der
kiefern gesteine hinterlassen haben
nachdem wir nun gezielt suchen können
diese theorien zum ursprung des
irdischen was macht die existenz von
wasser auf exoplaneten und damit auch
außerirdisches leben noch ein stückchen
wahrscheinlicher denn nicht nur die erde
sondern eben auch exoplaneten könnten
auf diesem weg zu wasser gekommen sein
auch ohne hast du eben dazu wo unser
modell deutlich darauf hin dass die
bildung von wasser fast schon
zwangsweise auf jedem ausreichend roten
gesteinsplaneten erfolgen würde
ich finde das ziemlich spannend und es
bestätigt immer mehr die these dass eben
leben keine ausnahme im weltall ist
sondern die regel
es wird also wirklich immer
wahrscheinlicher und nicht mehr lange
dauern bis wir auf solches leben stoßen
werden hier auf klicks um erfahrt dass
dann natürlich mit als erstes wenn er
kein video dazu verpassen wollt dann
abonniert klicks um auch auf englisch
denn auch da gibt es immer wieder
videopremieren einfach dafür hier
draufklicken und da drunter geht es
weiter mit
exciting discovery snow bigbank bis bald
hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
kanal csu
stay tuned